[Aplausos]
no me hagan sentir solo
para mí hoy día súper difícil quiero
decir bien franco con mucho respeto
cerrar cerrar esto porque un puro genio
antes que yo
yo podría nombrar a cada uno que me dejó
impresionado desde el asombro porque a
mí la ciencia no se me dan a mí nunca me
he menor por otro en ciencia naturales
use las de éste porque llegué a la casa
booster algodón
después crezco y tengo hermanos soy el
sexto de siete todo se comprenderá que
no soy hijo del amor su hijo la
obligación y lo tratan todo científico
mi hermano se fue los 19 años a estados
unidos boston porque ya estaba la
ciencia entonces tengo tengo los dos
lados los hermanos bueno los mayores son
como hijo del amor otros somos como
tumores que van llegando bueno lo más
chico pero pregunta entonces tengo el
típico hermano que dice perdón
todo es matemática
y el otro te dice nada
para qué sirven las matemáticas para que
estudió ciencia para que estudia
matemáticas pues no la voy a usar
entonces en esta cosa te tiran pica me
empiezo a formar en una casa donde no
eran nadie muy cuerdo debo reconocerlo
porque va a tener siete hijos siendo
profesor universitario mi padre no podía
ser muy cuerdo
partiendo por mi abuelo que estaba
estudiando arquitectura en trieste y
lanza una moneda al aire porque quería
reconstruir terremoto de 1906 valparaíso
todo noticias patrimoniales lo hizo este
abuelo era otro vuelo llegas de una
materia estructural ya no va a poner un
comercio entonces antes morir mi abuela
cuando él salió tengo ya un teatro
mesero berto tú tienes que saber cómo la
gente chiles
a un elemento una cosa decía circo y hay
cuatro a la vez muy bien que tú vendas
cinco poblar este otro palo otro por
cuando yo puse lo emporio en valparaíso
tuve dos puertas entonces la gente más
elegante entrada por la calle blanco
porque nosotros con la que entra por la
calle cochrane eso es chile le vende lo
mismo lo mismo pero no se mezclan
kimco clase marketing
y cuando estoy en valparaíso han visto
algo más triste que valparaíso en la
época nuestra bueno la vea trillo son
somos familia numerosa su padre de
quilpué también
a roberto pero
lo que pasa es que para adherir a
santiago en ese entonces para hoy en
santiago estudiar teatro porque la
escuela en valparaíso fue cerrada por
razones ambientales de la época igual
que el acuerdo periodismo entonces que
dando posibilidad venir a santiago
significaba un viaje en unos buses que
eran tóxicos de su vida y morías en el
camino de la contaminación se llama
antes mar bus era horroroso por la
cuesta pero se cometieron al pie del
citroneta 18 este p nos traía toro
sobrino a santiago nunca supe cómo
sobrevivimos a esas tías y esas madres
que tuvimos y a las nanas que nos
criaron yo me crié en una escuela de la
lógica quiero llegar dónde quiero ir en
mi casa quinta no 9 en quilpué de perdón
con mis padres había un pozo que había
sido ya declarado como cuando ya están
obsoletas ya nada más agua grupos o
profundo profundo y estaba abierto
porque era muy grande y jugamos toda la
casa quinta y mi mamá aplicó media
primer auxilio de madre junto a los más
chicos que éramos nosotros lo dice como
una piedra no tomamos tira el pozo para
vite la piedra
y eso le pasa a los niños contentos que
se acercan y segundo quedó claro
pero los 12 años a mi mamá nos pasó la
llave y nos dijo ustedes ya estoy
cansado todos los chicos si quizá que
que hay normal en la casa mientras vivan
bajo mi techo la norma la pongo eta les
suena es eso es traicionar pero me dio
alas y empecé a ir de esa por la
universidad al paraíso y tenía 12 13
años yo había hecho la televisión ante a
los 7 años siempre primero una masa mal
quiero ser como mi hermana tía ganó el
premio crean de la época años 67 yo
tenía 7 años que sucia con diapositivas
entonces decía quiero ser maquinista
para la foto al maquinista otro quería
ser no sé aviador un bimotor en esa
época hoy yo quiero ser científico y un
laboratorio y empecé a descubrir lo que
era la fascinación y yo creo hoy día
chiquillo y se lo digo a usted que están
aquí en esta charla tan entretenía la
charla
que yo estoy otra vez como este niño que
mira asombrado que mira asombrado porque
uno trae de la profesión y lo puedo
decir después tengo 58 lleva algún
tiempo en esto ganando de la vida yo
estoy atrás con otra cosa
uno trae la profesión el niño que fue tu
mientras está estudiando pasarelas tu
vida es porque cuando uno se dona a la
vocación hay el ego que te hace una
trampa el ego es un pequeño argentino
que todos tenemos dentro
que muchas veces puede decir porque no
se me da porque me tienen mala porque el
profe esto porque el estado regido de
usted que la mayoría tengo entendido que
son otro número tengo nada que ver con
eso como le digo mis amigos de
matemática entre las profesiones
ordenadas pero se preguntaba a hernán
que a mí me después que lo escuché a
cada uno de ellos me entraron varias
preguntas y me encantaría hacerlo con
respecto a la infancia cada uno porque
esa pasión esa entrega en un país de
[ __ ] donde nada importa nada sabe lo
que pasa que nada importa nada yo cuando
escucho veo que los veo a usted este
lugar lleno me emociona de verdad como
un niño otra vez diciendo que gente
valiosa que hay porque la ciencia que
cuesta mucho comunicar si hoy día la
ciencia en chile- comunica era mejor
créanme que los candidatos presenciales
hablarían de ciencias hoy día y me decía
en la investigación ocupa el 0.4 por
ciento del pib de llegar a un 3 mínimo
si tenemos el observatorio debería
existir ese apoyo es el importarme a mí
que soy actor del importarle al
comerciante el médico
al abogado pero estamos en la costa muy
ramplona muy chica lo que decía mauricio
electro con el escritor un niño que lee
un libro único nunca más va a estar solo
hoy día yo me pasa de que siento de que
hay un divorcio profundo en cada una de
las parcelas que nosotros tenemos y que
agradezco también invitado aprendí
muchísimo y día pero sobre todo vuelvo a
insistir que nosotros traemos al oficio
el niño que fuimos y hay que ir apagando
el ego el ego sirva como nos vestimos
pero no para es trampa porque trampa
mantener siempre cuando usted en
valparaíso el paraíso está muy cerca a
santiago
entonces no pasaba nada cuando hizo la
ley de televisión en chile al canal
nuestro mar paraíso no sonaron porque
sea el legislador dijo en la ley
solamente los canales que tengan
domicilio en santiago pueden llegar a
todo chile y por eso alfonso dijo usted
podría estar mejor y sabe no está mejor
porque estuvo muchos años ilegales
transmitiendo en santiago cuando
partimos con el privado un poquito antes
yo le dan utilice su programa apertura
política
el gerente producción dijo nos vamos
subir a santiago que no seamos
en la clandestina mejor pedí perdón que
doy permiso
pero lo hicimos lo hicimos y para
nosotros era un problema porque como
antes toda la publicidad yo mediante la
publicidad un cierta radio maravilloso
ruta de acelerar de portal entonces me
decía yo vendo la policía te en quien
almorzará con los clientes y tenés que
ir a contar lo que era el programa
porque quiero se veía porque el
transmisor para poderlo mirar los
chiquillos deben colocar un alicate y
dar vuelta a la antena así manual porque
esa era la transmisión y repente alguien
dijo hagamos una cosa fantasía hagamos
que hacemos entonces yo partí el
programa lo mío era un mono que tenía el
títere
y nunca se va a olvidar que los primeros
segmentos el pipiripau formosa la
técnica y este mono que conmigo descubrí
al mundo y existían los documentales
alemanes de ciencia de tecnología y ahí
fue cuando sor partimos con las primeras
pinturas que fue lo primero privado
después las carta lectura carta mientras
venían los mono animados tuvo la gran
suerte que japón como país y su invadir
américa ustedes comen su chip porque
vieron el principado
porque porque los japoneses cuando
descubrieron el mercado americano y la
interesante ellos vendieron el país
entonces el galo auto japonés llegó a la
comunidad japonesa y a nosotros nos
ofreció los monos gratis en un canal
chico picante la fotografía salía de mi
casa no te estoy viendo y nunca dimos
cuenta y la única se le fue que el
director del canal que era un genio
genio y el mejor científico que yo
conocido se que el transmisor
no estoy deseando que sea así para ir a
arreglar con un pelito
tú sabes mira
pero salíamos y sin presupuesto en
presupuesto atomizado y así fue
y así fue como fuimos logrando la
identidad porque él tuvo la dispensa
dijo chuta nos censuraron el noticiario
pidieron una censura son forma elegante
decir porque te decían se recomienda que
no vayan más el aire quién te recomienda
bueno es que tenían en ese momento el
poder y algo más que sustenta al poder
entonces eliminamos noticiario porque en
el paraíso todo es trágico cuando se
incendiaba el paraíso es un mega
incendio y desde ocurre la pobreza que
nadie quiere mirar entonces era incómodo
en un país que tiene que vender el dólar
fácil año 81 82 que estamos felices un
incendio que al asco a un terremoto mal
paraíso lo echa abajo que gracia que
tengo el paraíso gracias a que hemos
pobre gracias timo de repente el chrome
aquí
alguien dijo inventemos que el fantasma
vuelve algún fantasma como vuela la mamá
mis hijo hizo la escenografía que era
como verónica la ilustradora como gris
hacía una ilustración de chiquititas el
director dijo probemos esto tenemos la
cámara
chrome aquí chrome aquí era el estudio
nuestro muy chico pintamos sobre el piso
pintamos azul
y el actor que se ha fantasma qué
fantástico él se ponía todo azul de
abajo con esta capa y empezamos el que
podía volar
los niños lo compraron altiro
pero nos falta el pelo tubo adulto dice
se le ven los productos mira el hueón
porque el adulto ya acabó
renuncien al adulto en la carrera
fascinante de nuevo yo estaba y yo
siempre fui actor para lo que dice en
televisión hasta que un día estoy en la
peluquería y no porque ya cuando pesa
falta a faltarme pelo me rapó no me
compleja no tener pelo lo que falta la
azotea sobre el sótano pero
quiero decir que estoy instalado en la
peluquería y al lado de un señor
psiquiatra y me dice oye
parto tuvo tu madre cuando te tuve
y yo le digo es un créeme que no lo sé
porque en quilpué se les debe pasar la
partera era una única señor al hospital
de quilpué no tenía muy buena fama al
hospital de que tú te iba a morir no ser
así era [ __ ] o casi a nacer en las casas
total de señal agua caliente en la misma
los pagos en la clínica tabancura no sea
clínica santa maría y ella no atendía en
la casa entonces llegó a la llegó con
este título pero por qué no me dijo tú
tienes una cabeza con la cual siempre
vas a seguir adelante
y yo le digo por qué por qué por la
forma que tenéis tan deforme de cabeza
tuviste un parto complicado y ahí está
la clave de tu vida
y yo de repente llegó a mi casa y le
pregunté a mi madre y mi madre santa
señora antes de morir le pregunto está
menos mal que no se murió en falta como
ratón pero entró la hoya se murió de
repente como segura vamos cansada pero
que se pare la revelación digo mamá que
parto tuve yo
eso es grave mi mamá
reparte tu amigo cuando te estaba
teniendo me bajo una crisis pensando
este niño va a sufrir mucho y te trate
de retener y la partera de
y ahí salí con la cabeza que salí
de una forma rara con la cabeza así
porque cuando dice clases en la
universidad católica en periodismo me di
cuenta de algo los hijos necesaria sean
por el lado no en frente a los problemas
los que han nacido por cesárea carbón
están dispuesto de repente programa la
cesárea porque ante la cesárea se
programaba científicamente de acuerdo
una emergencia médica ahora
se programa de acuerdo a las deudas el
doctor entonces el doctor se paga el
dividendo día 15 toda la uagn hasta
entre el 2 y el 3 a 2 en lagos está
tranquila fa y la sacan entonces evita
ese estrés que es tan importante en la
lucha te va a tocar ser luchador te va a
tocar entender lo único que les pido hoy
día por favor que este regalo que han
sido estas charlas por los expositores
crecen tuvimos que nos han situado otra
vez como niños me encanta esta cosa de
la astronomía porque nos da una visión
que es muy teatral cuando un niño hace
teatro en uvi que se ubica en el espacio
soy el protagonista de esto soy el
antagonista soy el personaje secundario
pero cuando tú decirse protagonista a tu
vida tiene que declarar que porque una
galaxia igual que una con esas un mínimo
de 6 chile en el mapa mil cuando dice
hoy estudiaste 45 en persona un estadio
nunca es tanto público en un txoko
infantil como en el sausalito consulta
con ti bilbao
pero pues cuando llegue mi casa mis
amigos trajiste pan y yo venía con el
estrellato arriba y esa es la realidad
después de me pasó que tengo 35
maravillosos y me sirvió mucho
a centrar a los partos por quién hacer
la vida no es natural es sobrenatural
un milagro esa cuestión o sea hay un
parto te agarra tu señora llega el
ginecólogo la es así de la parte por la
mitad y eso no es científico el tajo el
ginecólogo tiene pariente flaites o
antepasado porque bueno el cuchillo así
a la superfecta y te deja a la mujer
partida en dos web y tú mira y para
dentro si esto me como no entonces te
sacan la guagua
y qué pasa en la guagua tu mujer está
partida en dos te pasa en la guagua te
dice se parece al papá hay castigo más
injusto que eso y ahí a mí me bajó y me
puse como evangélico con pastor soto
estos vinos como son mía no puede ser
el único problema que tiene colo aspira
pero lo que estoy contando aspiro y
salta sangre de tuzsa y sangre
y bueno mi exmujer dijo gordy de alto
como estáis feliz
eso sobrenatural
y ello me di cuenta la maravilla que
estar vivo y me dio un alivio increíble
cuando yo era chico y nos contaron los
socios que somos finitos que vamos a
morir que lo único seguro que cuando
esta es la vida cabrón
no perdáis el tiempo en tonteras
atrévete a cambiar detrás de cada uno
estos amigos que hablaron antes hay una
historia de coraje
es tan importante saber comunicar y
cuando escuché la chiquita que pinta me
di cuenta de algo que le quiero regalar
que la mejor clase astronomía que lo
escribió un amigo muy querido otro lo
hizo popular y se la quiero que escuchen
la letra y con esto me despido que es el
abrazo del arte a la astronomía y que se
hace con un mensaje del año 67 ven hasta
ni soñado que en existir maestro el tema
número uno
vélez fuerte
[Música]
el sol persigue a la luna la luna se
esconderán así amanece el día así fue y
el así será el día y la noche son juegos
son juegos de luna y sol un dicen que
ser directamente en el suelo será dolor
o dicen que secretamente el sol se
enamoró la luna es femenina el sol es un
señor de la luna que aparece y el sol
que este año no sea el color sí señor
es como la noche
[Música]
el sol persigue a la luna la luna se
esconderá
y amanecer el día así fue y así sea
en el día y la noche son juegos son
juegos de luna y sol dicen que
secretamente el sol se enamoró dicen que
secretamente erizo él se llamó 2
esta canción es la cantamos los niños se
traducía me pongo liguera lo escribió
amigos y telecinco les
[Música]
el sol persigue a la luna la luna se
esconderá hacia allá amanece el día así
huellas ligeras
el día y la noche son juegos son juegos
de luna y sol dicen 10 secretamente el
sol se enamoró dicen que secretamente el
sol senna
recupera que a ver el chico interior y
la de la escuela universidad el después
de en la vida habrás en la vida como una
conquista no esperéis que otro lo hará
por ti
único mensaje viva la vida
[Aplausos]